Меморіальний комплекс в невеликому
німецькому селищі на кордоні Баварії і Чехії.
Колишній концентраційний табір "Флоссенбюрг".
Тут протягом семи років утримували близько ста тисяч в'язнів,
30 000 з яких не дожили до звільнення табору в квітні 45-го.
Онуфрій Михайлович Дудок пройшов
через кілька нацистських таборів, зокрема й Освенцім.
На каторжних роботах у Флоссенбюргу перебував більше року.
Сьогодні йому 92. З рідного Львова на щорічну зустріч тих, хто вижив,
він у супроводі перекладача приїжджає вже не вперше.
Проходячи, в прямому сенсі слова, до болю знайомими коридорами,
згадує, в яких нелюдських умовах доводилося виживати.
Вікна у нас були відкриті тут і тут.
І один коцик на двох.
Той тягне на себе, я на себе.
Боже...
То було так: як він і той другий,
бо то були поодинці ліжка,
плече в плече всі
притулились
і то той нагрів такий сохранявся.
Серед колишніх в'язнів "Флоссенбюрга", які в цьому році
змогли особисто приїхати на річницю визволення табору,
Онуфрій Михайлович - єдиний виходець з колишнього Радянського Союзу.
Таких, як він, тільки за офіційними даними,
тут було понад 20 тисяч. Про каторжні роботи по 12 годин на день
в гранітних каменоломнях "Флоссенбюрга"
колишні в'язні розповідають сьогодні всіма мовами Європи.
Найважче було переставляти рельси,
то є рейси, що вагонки пхалися,
з камінням. Їх треба було
пересувати то туда, то сюда.
Каждий прийшов з роботи, сів отак і так дрімав,
чекали 9-ї вечора, бо скорше не можна було йти спати.
А як вже 9-та єсть,
пішов, ліг і заснув...
Тіко заснув, а то вже будять.
В четвертій годині вже вставай.
Дізнатися більше про історію колишнього концтабору
можна не тільки з розповідей очевидців,
але й звернувшись до архіву меморіалу.
У дні річниці закінчення війни відвідувачів особливо багато.
Родичі тих, чиє життя обірвалося в катівнях нацистських таборів,
приїжджають в надії розшукати інформацію
про зниклих безвісти.
Протягом усього життя моя бабуся
шукала інформацію про свого батька,
який зник безвісти. І три роки тому, коли почали викладати архіви,
ми знайшли інформацію про його пересування, про те, як він потрапив у полон.
І дізналися, що він загинув у концтаборі "Флоссенбюрг".
Подібних запитів з роками не меншає,
постійно надходять нові. Допомогти вдається,
на жаль, не всім, але кожна знахідка має значення,
яке важко переоцінити.
Для родичів це досить часто стає несподіванкою.
Багато сімей зі Східної Європи, з Росії, Білорусії, України
досі не знають, що сталося з їхніми родичами.
І, звичайно, для них це дуже емоційно, коли вони
завдяки нашим пошукам нарешті знаходять могили рідних.
За традицією, вшановуючи жертв концтабору,
молодь приносить до меморіалу квіти.
На гранітних плитах викарбувані прапори тих країн,
з яких в'язнів зганяли сюди, під Флоссенбюрг,
і цифри: кількість тих, хто так і не повернувся додому з нацистського полону.
Ні на мінутку не забуваю
того, що я був у ув'язненні.
Мені постоянно в мозгах то всьо сидить.
Постоянно.
І воно не виходить ніколи: я лягаю спати - воно зі мною,
я встаю - воно зі мною,
постійно воно зі мною.
Отак.
Ті ж, кому пощастило залишитися живим,
знову і знову повертаються туди,
де колись давно все ж вдалося вижити.